John Wick might be known as the Baba
Yaga to his foes but did you know that
the name has a deep meaning rooted in
Russian folklore not all Boogeyman are
created equal while many action heroes
have been revered by the characters of
their fictional realities few seem to
inspire the kind of dread and awe that
Keanu Reeves John Wick does an utter
legend of the Underworld the well-known
assassin and Hitman came out of
retirement in his original outing and
has been shedding blood relentlessly
ever since but now yeah I'm thinking I'm
back one of the most notable
characteristics of John Wick however is
his unique nickname in the vicious
circles that the character travels
through he is referred to as Baba Yaga
while many may be unaware of its Origins
particularly in North America denizens
of Europe will likely be more familiar
with the folklore behind the foreboding
Name a creature of Russian folklore Baba
Yaga is something of a Slavic Boogeyman
or boogie woman as the case might be
like many societies the Slavic peoples
told Tales of a frightening soup
Supernatural force that would come to
punish children if they behaved badly or
wandered off alone though most cultures
throughout history have a similar figure
like Spain's sack man or Brazil's Kuka
part of what makes Baba Yaga so scary is
how downright strange she is though John
Wick might be terrifying in his own
right he's got nothing on the bizarre
and nightmarish stories of Baba Yaga the
witch is set to keep her collection of
human skulls on a fence as a warning to
any unlucky enough to stumble upon her
Lair and if she's looking for you she
has no shortage of terrifying ways to
track you down Baba Yaga has a flying
Kettle that she can use to stalk her
victims from above and she is also said
to have a flying mortar that she can
pilot with a magical pestle if you think
that's as weird as it gets then hold on
to your flying kettles because Baba Yaga
also lives in a hut that can run around
the woods on giant chicken legs while
that might sound absolutely Bonkers you
have to admit that the prospect of being
chased through the forest by a cottage
on bird legs is pretty frightening
however there are less outwardly strange
aspects of Baba Yaga that might help to
explain why John Wick is known by this
name in the criminal underworld one
thing we all know about John Wick is
that when he's out for blood a lot of
people are about to die being that Baba
Yaga is said to regularly join death on
his travels this adds context to why the
Assassin has been branded with this
moniker in fact the witch's reason for
following death is so that she can
devour The Souls of the newly dead
is it a child it's just a human child
many of us today aren't as worried today
about what happens to us after death but
in the past the prospect of not being
allowed to move on to the afterlife was
a very real terror for people of many
cultures terms like the last rites or a
Christian burial are still known to us
to this day there are similar beliefs
from older cultures that suggest that if
a person is not properly laid to rest
they may wander forever or even risk
damnation the fact that Baba Yaga
doesn't just arrive with death but seems
to erase you from existence could add to
the reasoning behind John Wick's
nickname as well while most Tales of
Baba Yaga see her as a mysterious and
capricious villain and a terrifying
Supernatural Force she is known to
appear in other forms and even help
humans from time to time however since
Baba Yaga is said to have two sisters
who share her name it's possible that it
is these versions of the mythological
figure that the more fortunate
characters have run into in such stories
like Loki of Norse mythology Baba Yaga
can be seen as a friend or a foe
depending on the circumstances while
enemies of John Wick might see him as a
dangerous force to be reckoned with WIC
also has a moral code and is likely to
help someone he cares for or relates to
despite his knack for a killer be killed
brutality bedtime Tales of John Wick is
the Baba Yaga could be at an end
following John Wick chapter 4. however
fans can still hold out hope that his
name will continue to haunt them in more
movies like The Immortal folktale figure
for which he's named
[Music]